In this problem we're told that to an observer down here Andy,
who is standing 2 m away but who is 1 m above the ground,
will look just as tall as this church 90 m away.
The trick to solving this problem is to realize that in order for the building and Andy
to look the same height from the observer's perspective down here,
we have to be able to connect a line that goes from the top of the building
through Andy's head and finally ends at the observer's eyes.
When we draw these lines corresponding to the height of the building
and the height of Andy, we get these nice similar triangles.
Now, we don't know anything about the angles of these triangles,
except for the fact that these are right angles, but we don't need to.
Remember that with similar triangles we have this nice property
that the ratio of any two corresponding sides of the smaller triangle
and the larger triangle have to be equal.
This means that the ratio of 1 m to 2 m
has to be exactly the same as the ration of the height of the church
to the distance the church is away from the viewpoint of the observer.
We can express this relationship using this equation here.
That 1/2 is exactly equal to the height of the building,
which I've labeled here with a question mark, over 90 m.
Using this equation to solve for the height of the building,
I find that the building is 45 m off the ground. Great job.